moment außerirdische aufgespürt nasa
kündigt pressekonferenz an und damit
herzlich willkommen wirklich vom science
fiction laut nasa werden wir in den
nächsten 20 jahren alien entdecken ist
es jetzt schon so weit die nager kündigt
sogar eine pressekonferenz an
was erwartet uns die frage nach leben im
all beschäftigt forscher schon seit
ewigkeiten um zu leben benötigt der
mensch wasser deshalb suchen astronomen
danach in allen möglichen formen auf
extrasolaren planeten kurs exoplaneten
planeten die um andere sterne als unsere
sonne kreisen
bei ihrer suche profitieren sie davon
dass manche planeten von der erde aus
gesehen in regelmäßigen abständen vor
ihrem stern vorbei wandern dabei
durchleuchtet er die planeten atmosphäre
denn je nach ihrer chemischen
zusammensetzung absorbiert die planeten
atmosphäre unterschiedlich viel licht
und unterschiedliche wellenlängen mit
dieser methode konnten forscher bereits
wasser in der atmosphäre einiger
riesenplaneten nachweisen julien die mit
vom massachusetts institute of
technology kit zufolge werden wir noch
in unserer generation herausfinden ob
diese planeten bewohnen die tat
eine der größten fragen unserer zeit ob
wir allein im universum sind wir leben
in einer zeit in der die menschheit
diese frage wissenschaftlich beantworten
kann
das erklärt paul hertz von der nasa
wissenschaftlich betrachtet gibt es
lebensfreundliche planeten sie liegen in
den sogenannten habitablen zonen um
einen stern herum dort ist es nicht zu
kalt und nicht zu warm proxima centauri
b den forschern zufolge einer dieser
vielversprechenden kandidaten in einem
match zeitraum von 54 nächten sammelten
experten mit hilfe des harps
spektrographen am 3,6 meter teleskop des
la villa auf der hut und viele wertvolle
informationen über das thema centauri b
der planet bewegt sich in einer
entfernung von sieben millionen
kilometern um seinen eigenen stern er
besitzt ähnlich wie unser heimatplanet
einen tag und nacht zyklus außerdem
liegt er in einer habitablen und für uns
leicht erreichbaren zone und zu guter
letzt bietet proxima centauri b gute
voraussetzung für das lebenselexier
schlechthin was von bugs in der
atmosphäre wasser auf proxima centauri b
es wird spannend immer mehr
diese exoplaneten werden entdeckt mehr
als 3000 sind bis heute entdeckt worden
und über 300 davon sind ehrt ähnlich
dort könnte es also leben geben jetzt
für dinara der welt also neue
erkenntnisse präsentieren den link zur
pressekonferenz findet ihr in der video
beschreibung ihr könnt euch übrigens
auch gerne hier unter dem video in den
kommentaren zu dieser pressekonferenz
austauschen wir werden sie natürlich
auch mitverfolgen
und hier könnt ihr noch ein abo aufs
auge drücken und vergesst nicht mehr
noch einen auf die glocke zu geben
manche sondern nur darauf warten also
bis 19 uhr in den kommentaren und bis
dann bleib dran